Çeviri: Zisan Bas
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Hadi, hadi Ankara bir elleri göreyim.
Alkışları göreyim.
Hadi enerjiniz tükendi mi ya?
Tabii, otur otur laktik asit birikti.
Hemen atacağız.
Kaldır kolları, kaldır kolları.
Laktik asidi atmanın en kolay yolu
açma germe yapmaktır
şöyle iyice gökyüzüne ulaşırcasına
göreyim elleri, hazır elleri kaldırmışken
pençeleri hazırlayalım
üçe kadar sayacağım, kükreyeceksiniz.
Hadi bakalım Ankara
Bir, iki, üç!
İyi sayılır ama ben bir örnek göstereyim
onu yapalım.
Kükreme dediğimiz şey şöyle bir şey.
Kaldır elleri, pençeler hazır
üçe kadar sayıyorum.
Bir, iki, üç!
(Seyirci kükrüyor)
Harikasınız ama aşk olmadan
hiçbir şey olmaz.
O yüzden de bir tane romantik
kükreme alacağız.
Romantik kükremeye örnek
gösteriyorum
çünkü romantik kükreme deyince herkesin
kafasında başka bir şey canlanıyor.
Romantik kükreme şöyle bir şey.
Hadi bakalım kaldır elleri Ankara
pençeler hazır.
Üçe kadar sayıyorum romantik kükreme için.
Bir, iki, üç!
Harikasınız, alkış.
(Alkışlama)
Bendeniz bir psikoloğum.
2000 yılında Orta Doğu Teknik
Üniversitesİ psikoloji
bölümünden mezun oldum
asıl çalışma alanım: performans.
Bugün size gelgit dediğimiz şeyin
psikolojide
nasıl yönetileceğini anlatacağım.
Böyle bir iyi hissetme, bir kötü hissetme
hâli gün içerisinde.
Herhangi bir şey olur ve yaşarsınız
problem değil.
Önemli olan onu yönetmek.
Onu yönetebilmek için beynimiz
nasıl çalışıyor bir bakalım.
Elimizi ensemize koyalım
şu anda hayvan beyninize dokunuyorsunuz.
Elimizi bir alnımıza koyalım.
Şu anda insan beyninize dokunuyorsunuz.
Aralarındaki oran korkunç
%96 hayvan beyin
%4 insan beyin.
%96'sı olumsuzun peşinden koşuyor.
Çünkü seni hayatta tutmaya çalışıyor.
O yüzden de kötü hissetmeye zemin
çok müsait.
Hele hele kötü hissettiğinde, o duyguya
bir de tutunursan.
İşte o zaman işler karışıyor.
Peki nasıl olacak da tutunmayacağız?
İlk yapmamız gereken şey, kendini kötü
hissettiğinde insan vücudu içe kapanır.
Onun için hemen hareketlendirmek gerekiyor
Deneyelim, elleri yumruk yap
kaldır havaya.
Bir, iki, üç, dört, beş, altı, yedi
sekiz, dokuz, on!
İndir, şimdi gelseler tükürükten
örnek alsalar
çoktan serotonin ve endorfin
salgıladın bile.
O yüzden kendini kötü hissettiğinde
hemen kalk, hareketlen.
Açma germe yap, en iyisidir.
Şimdi tabi, kendini kötü hissettiğinde
sana seni iyi hissettirebilecek birisiyle
keşke konuşabilsen
yüz yüze olursa çok iyi
ama olmadı hemen aç telefonu, sana
seni iyi hissettirecek birisiyle konuş.
Ben bir gün böyle çok yoğun
çalışıyorum, işler güçler
uçaklar koşturmaca, sahneye çıkacağım
insanlara enerji vermem lazım.
Anamı aradım, iyi hissettirir değil mi
anne sesi?
Aradım "nasılsın annem?" dedim,
"kötüyüm" dedi.
(Gülüşme)
"Ne oldu" dedim ya, işte "buram ağrıyor
şuram ağrıyor"
Girmedim topa, olumsuz ya
baktı ben topa girmiyorum.
"Baban da kötü" dedi.
(Gülüşme)
"Ne oldu anne?" dedim
"Doktorun verdiği ilaç işe yaramadı" dedi.
Anlattı, anlattı
Ben gene girmedim topa.
"Fatma teyzen de çok hasta" dedi.
(Gülüşme)
Fatma teyzeyi tanımıyorum
iki dakika dinledim.
Baktı ben yine topa girmiyorum.
Dedi ki "Türkiye'nin durumu
nereye gidiyor?"
Ben yine topa girmeyince
''Buzlar eriyor ne yapacağız?'' dedi.
Global bir sorun
dedim ki "Anne bak, ben kendimi
iyi hissetmek için seni aradım"
"Sen neler yapıyorsun, bir kural
koyalım üç olumsuza bir olumlu anlat."
Düşündü, düşündü bir şey bulamadı.
Dedim ki "Ben sana yardım edeyim"
"Sen dün gece yattın uyudun
sabah uyandın değil mi anne?" dedim.
"Evet" dedi
"Bazı insanlar dün gece yattı uyudular"
"ve sabah uyanamadılar"
Uzunca bir sessizlik oldu.
Sonra annem dedi ki
"Sen benim ölmemi mi istiyorsun?"
"Anne" dedim "eyvah eyvah"
Elbette sorunlarla başa çıkmak için
sevdiğimiz insanların sorunlarını
dinleyeceğiz ama iyi hissetmek için
bir şeyler yapmak lazım bak kötü
hissettiğinde dinlediğin müzik çok önemli.
Şu müzikleri dinleme.
Şarkıyı biliyor muyuz?
Hadi hep beraber söyleyelim mi?
Hadi, her şey karanlık nerede insanlık
kula kulluk edene, yazıklar olsun!
Hadi geliyor.
Allah Allah!
Hoppa! Eyvah!
Abi ne yaptık ya?
Bu bizi iyi hissettirmez
bir gün seminerdeyiz bu şarkıyı çaldım.
Bir hanımefendi itiraz etti.
Dedi ki, bu şarkı çok iyi bir şarkı.
Dedim ki şarkıya iyi kötü demiyorum
ama bu şarkının sözleriyle bir yere
gidemeyiz, hemen çevirdi dedi ki
ben zaten sadece müziğini dinliyorum.
Ha dedim yani beyin yolda ikiye ayırıyor
bunları, bak bende ki alternatif bu.
Eller, hadi Ankara!
Hop, hop hadi!
İyi değil mi, daha iyi değil mi?
Hop!
Evet arkada dans edenler görüyorum.
Hadi, eller, eller, eller!
Evet harikasınız!
Bu bizi hareketlendirir ya.
Bunları deneyelim yani.
Peki, şimdi kendini kötü hissettiğinde
böyle bir "of of" çekme hikâyesi vardır.
Hemen deneyeceğiz
üçe kadar sayacağım, "of of" çekeceğiz.
Bir, iki, üç!
Seyirci: of of
Bu ne arkadaş dokunsak ağlayacaksınız ya.
Bak of of çektin mi patinaja girersin
ben de alternatif var hadi hazırla.
Hadi hadi hadi, sesleri duyayım
hadi, bir, iki, üç!
Oley! Hadi hep beraber yapıyoruz hadi
hazır mısınız? Bir, iki üç!
Seyirci: Oley!
Hadi bir daha!
İşte bununla kalkarsan, yola çıkarsan
her şey daha güzel olacaktır.
Peki kendini kötü hissettin
iyi bir nefes bizi kendimize getirir.
Üçe kadar sayacağım, bir nefes alacağız
sonra bırakacağız, hadi.
Bir, iki, üç!
Al
Bırak
Bak iyidir, geçen gün seminerde biri
böyle yapıyor.
Dedim ne yapıyorsun?
Daha iyi gelir diye tuttum dedi.
Yapma dedim ya yapma.
Bak kendini kötü hissettiğinde
beynini o esnada içine girdiği
o düşünce çemberinden çıkartman gerekiyor
hani derler ya
10'a kadar say, derin nefes al diye.
Bence derin nefes alırken bir de
böyle elini şıklat ki başka
bir uyaran daha gönder beynine.
Hadi, hadi, hadi
Daha güçlü, sesi duyayım
Hadi, hop!
Hop! Haydi!
Ee Ankara'dayız, Ankara'nın bağları
olmadan olmaz.
Hop, hop!
Yine görüyorum bazıları oynuyor galiba.
Hadi, hop hop!
Evet, harikasınız teşekkürler.
Bak mesaj kısa kendini kötü
hissettiysen içindeki ritim duygusunu
bir harekete geçir, dans et
ama etmiyoruz, düğünden düğüne.
Burada da böyle ilginç sohbetler oluyor.
"Kalkmazsan ölümü gör"
(Gülüşme)
Daha kötüsü var
"Kalkmazsan ölümü öp"
Nereye gidiyor bu muhabbet?
Yapmayın yapmayın.
Şimdi biz tabii teması seven varlıklarız,
temas edince oksitosin salgılıyoruz,
güven hormonu.
Hadi herkes bir birbiriyle el sıkışsın.
Hadi bakalım görelim.
Hadi önün, arkan, sağın, solun.
Bir el sıkış.
Harika!
Bak bunu bir adım daha öteye
götürelim mi, hadi birbirimize sarılalım.
Hadi, hadi
Tanıdık, tanımadık önemli değil.
Harikasınız, harikasınız.
Muhteşem ya, salonun güzelliğine bak.
Çok iyi, çok iyi.
Harikasınız.
Şimdi tabii, psikolojik temas da önemli.
Yani birilerine "Günaydın" demek
"Merhaba" demek.
Apartmandayız, büyük bir apartman
asansöre bindim sabah.
Komşuma rastladım.
"Günaydın" dedim
Adam böyle cevap verdi.
Arkadaş, hayvan beyninle değil
insan beyninle.
Önemli olan birlikteliği arttırabilmek.
Havalimanında uçuyorum.
Orada böyle hani güvenlik kısmında
böyle eşyaları bırakıp geçiyorsun ya
hızlıdır orası böyle kavga dövüş falan.
Bir gün böyle tam bekliyorum.
Önümdeki kişi boş tepsiyi aldı.
Bana verdi, yardım etti.
Nasıl hoşuma gitti, kendimi
çok iyi hissettim.
Dönüş uçağındayız ben de deneyeyim
dedim, aldım tepsiyi
uzattım adama, böyle yaptı:
"Gerek yok kardeş"
Şimdi ben bu ikisinden yola çıkarak
bir daha birisine "günaydın" dermiyim?
bir daha birisine tepsi falan
uzatır mıyım?
İşte bu kötüye tutunmak arkadaşlar.
Ben günaydın demeye devam ettim.
Ben insanlara yardım etmeye
devam ettim.
Kendimizi iyi hissettirir
o yüzden bırakmayın.
Hep peşinden koşun
bir şeyler yapmak zorundayız.
Ancak, kendini iyi hissetmek için
bir şeyler yaparken
dikkat etmen gereken çok önemli
bir konu var.
Sana o yaptığın şey, şimdi
iyi hissettirir sonra kötü hissettirirse
işler karışıyor.
Bak bir gün diyelim ki
kendini kötü hissettin
açtın bir otuz beşlik ayran içtin.
Yetmedi üstüne bir de kalem
ayran içtin.
Böyle köpüklü köpüklü
Oh çok güzel, iyi hissediyorsun.
Sabah bir kalktın, bu hâldesin.
Bak bunu yapma.
Bak bunu yapma, bunu yapma.
Onun yerine
çok daha iyi şeyler var
ne olabilir mesela
hemen deneyelim, küçük bir sınav yapalım.
Size bir iyi hissetme şansı tanıyacağım.
Bakalım değerlendirebilecek misiniz?
Hep beraber şarkıyı söylüyoruz hadi.
Şarkıyı biliyorsunuz, hep beraber şarkıyı
söylüyoruz.
Bir rahat pozisyon alın bakalım.
Hadi
Hop
Mini mini bir kuş donmuştu.
Pencereme konmuştu.
Hareketleri de yapıyoruz hanımlar beyler.
Aldım onu içeriye.
Cik cik cik cik ötsün diye.
Pır pır ederken canlandı
ellerim bak boş kaldı.
Hadi bakalım, alkışlarla devam edelim.
Şarkı çok iyi gidiyor.
Hadi, hadi
Mini mini bir kuş donmuştu.
Pencereme konmuştu.
Aldım onu içeriye
Cik cik cik cik ötsün diye.
Pır pır ederken canlandı
ellerim bak boş kaldı.
Bravo, alkış!
Harikasınız, harikasınız
Şimdi bir gün tabii ben seminerde
bu şarkıyı çaldım.
Bir beyefendi elini kaldırdı dedi ki
"Çocuk şarkısıyla mı iyi hissediceğiz?"
Mızmızlamayın arkadaşlar.
İyilik, kötülük her yerde.
İyi, kötü hissetmek her an mümkün
Mızmızlama ya.
İçinde bir çocuk olduğuna inanıyorsun da,
niye bir çocuk şarkısı söylemiyorsun?
Seni kurtaracaksa söyle.
Yine bir gün bir seminerde
hanımefendinin biri kaldırdı elini
dedi ki "ya hocam" dedi,
"Bu bir ayrılık şarkısı değil mi?"
(Gülüşme)
Düşündüm şöyle, "evet" dedim "evet"
"Biz bununla nasıl mutlu olalım
nasıl iyi hissedelim?"
Bak artık hanımefendinin o olumsuz
bakan böyle kadrajlar
iyice buğulanmış böyle anladın mı
çok olumsuz yani.
Yapmayalım böyle, mızmızlamayın
kendiniz için bir şeyler yapın.
Önümüz 2017, yılbaşına gireceğiz.
Ben bu kadar büyük bir kalabalığı
bir daha denk getiremem.
Ben diyorum ki bir yılbaşına girelim.
Bir yılbaşına girelim.
Yılbaşı deyince tabii bir Noel baba lazım.
Ben olucam merak etmeyin
Şimdi yılbaşı olunca bir de tabii
İyi dilek de lazım.
İhtiyacımız olan şey barış
Öyle değil mi?
Ülkemiz için barış, huzur ve mutluluk
dileyerek 10'dan geriye sayalım.
Hep beraber 2017'ye girelim mi?
Hadi o zaman hazırsanız
On
Dokuz
Sekiz
Yedi
Altı
Beş
Dört
Üç
İki
Bir
Sıfır
(Alkışlama)
Çok güzelsiniz.
Harikasınız, harikasınız.
Harikasınız.
Bu ülkede bizi bir arada tutan
en önemli şey halay.
Tabii bu kadar yükselmişken halay çekmeden
hayatta bırakmam.
Bak bende mendili var.
Şimdi genelde halaya çık, çıkma
bilmem ne falan.
O biraz sıkıntılı oluyor.
Ben sizi hazırlayacağım.
Şu serçe parmaklarını şöyle havaya kaldır
tut yanındakinin serçe parmağını.
Hazır mıyız?
Müzik geliyor
Hop, harika.
Bak
Bin kişilik halay.
Ver biraz ses bana.
Hop
Harikasınız.
Biraz hızlanalım halaya.
Bak bak bak.
Arkada halayı kurdular bile.
Aferin size.
Harikasınız.
Hop
Hadi ön taraf kalk ayağa.
Hop, hop
Kalk, kalk, kalk!
Harikasın, harikasın Ankara!
Hop!
Çok güzel, çok güzel.
Alkışlar, alkışlar hepinize gelsin
hepinize gelsin.
Çok güzelsiniz.
Arkadaşlar
canlı yayınlanan organizasyonumuz
bütün dünyada, yeterli ilgiyi görmüş
durumda.
Ben, Tedx, Tedx olalı
böyle bir şey gördüğümüze inanmıyorum.
(Alkışlama)